let's dial in laura trump fox news
contributor who is from not far from
myrtle beach good morning to you laura
good morning
good morning that's right i'm from
wrightsville beach north carolina it's a
beautiful time of year down there it is
indeed hey uh laura what do you make of
the fact that now you know the
pentagon's going yeah uh general milley
called uh his counterpart in china to
warn him that if your unstable
father-in-law uh tried to start a war he
would stop it did general milly stab
your father-in-law in the back
it certainly appears that way steve um
and i i struggle to find another way to
see this quite frankly we now have
within the span of a little over a week
two phone calls that we've learned about
one from joe biden to the afghan
president and now this phone call of
mark millie's that would have certainly
resulted in an impeachment for donald
trump and yet i guess we've forgotten
now about the phone call joe biden had
we're just done with that one now we see
that obviously this was insubordinate uh
obviously the chain of command was
broken this borders on treason i i know
some people have said this is a
treasonous act
it doesn't matter guys whether or not
you like the president of the united
states whether you agree with him
politically that is the president of the
united states that is the commander in
chief and that is the individual that
calls the shots and needs to know about
phone calls like this yes we're finding
out there were more people that were
involved but if the president of the
united states himself did not know that
is a big problem
do you think i evidently that gap period
between the election day and january
20th the inauguration day the president
was incensed a lot of the time in fact
this is what one
quote was about general milley he says
he feared trump was suffering serious
mental decline how would you
characterize the former president during
that period
well that is an absurd uh reflection of
what actually happened well when you
have a very questionable election result
and you don't get results for quite some
time i think you probably would be a
little upset as well my father-in-law
when he was the president of the united
states had complete and total control of
everything by the way you contrast how
he acted as president versus joe biden
at least the world knew that we were
serious at least we weren't being
laughed at at least we weren't getting
13 service members killed over in
afghanistan while donald trump was in
office so i think it's a ridiculous
assessment i'm not surprised that that
is the characterization of somebody that
doesn't like him but i think we all know
that that was not the case according to
this book peril it says not only did
millie have this call with china telling
them look if we're going to attack you
i'll let you know in advance but it's
all they're also saying that nancy
pelosi called millie demanding the
nuclear football be taken away from your
father-in-law during this time period
and millie summoned his senior officials
and told them that he must be involved
in any decision to launch a nuclear
weapon and if that's the case is that
collusion this is what uh chris miller
he's the forming former acting secretary
of defense he says i did not authorize
these calls with china that's a
violation of duty he said pursuit of
partisan politics and individual
self-interest or a violation of an
officer's sacred duty and have no place
in the united states military a lesser
ranking officer accused of such behavior
would immediately be relieved of duty
pending a thorough and independent
investigation as secretary of defense i
did not and would not ever authorize
such conduct so if there is an
investigation and if it's true your
father-in-law is accusing him of treason
republicans are demanding that millie
resign will he resign do you think he
should
i don't know whether or not he will
resign i think he this is yet another
embarrassment for america and i think a
lot of people would like to see him
resign i think the very least we could
ask that uh we get some answers from him
that he we hear in a congressional
setting exactly what happened here we
certainly want to get the transcripts uh
the full transcripts from this call um
and i'm curious was nancy pelosi sworn
in as president of the united states and
none of us knew maybe she ought to
answer some questions too
it's a real debacle and quite a mess
right now i hope we can get this sorted
out and i hope it's not like everything
else that has happened under joe biden
where we just sweeping under the rug
well it's impossible to sweep under the
rug laura what's happening on our
southern border uh you know we showed
folks a moment ago
an image of 7 000 migrants under a
bridge waiting and look at this it's a
picture of a two-year-old
girl and her three-month-old baby
brother
somebody abandoned them down near del
rio texas
just you know waiting for the americans
to come and save their lives it's it's
just heartbreaking and then you look at
the bridge with 7 000 people underneath
they're just waiting to be apprehended
and now the news is
apparently the administration in their
wisdom has decided okay if you're a
migrant and you're coming into the
country we need to vaccinate you give
you at least one shot but only if you do
it legally if you're illegal you know
what you're not going to get a shot
i mean i just wonder sometimes how dumb
do they think the american people are
j what you just described there is
absurd the fact that we have a fully
open southern border that people can
just come on over it any any way they
want they don't need to be vaccinated um
i was watching the show earlier when it
was described exactly how this happens
they come over and then they are
transported
all across the united states of america
they're not tested for cobit they are
not vaccinated but back to that photo of
the two-year-old and the three-month-old
my daughter carolina just turned two
last month
this is a horrifying thing to see and
when is it enough where's aoc by the way
remember when she was crying down at the
southern border during the trump
administration about all the kids where
is she now i know she was busy at the
met gala flaunting around in that very
fancy dress of hers
why is there not more outrage from the
folks on the left about what is
happening at our southern border
especially to these kids 200 000 that we
know of last month alone if you
extrapolate that out over 12 months 2.4
million people illegally in america that
we have documented at this point think
about all those people that come over we
never know about guys all right laura
trump thanks so much appreciate it
thanks laura
thanks guys august august a year of 300
number of illegals
year to year